Jamie I thought a great place for us to
start this conversation is in the
differentiation you all have with many
other miners most miners are Bitcoin and
Bitcoin only and they're just focused on
go mine as much Bitcoin as you can and
survive the bear markets you all have
this Diversified approach where you are
Bitcoin miners but you also have a lot
of high uh computing power Computing
performance that you're looked at as
well can you help understand what is the
difference between just being Bitcoin
only versus some of the you know high
computational power that you all have
and then what are the advantages to
having more of a diversified strategy
yeah I'm happy to jump right in so I'll
take a step back a little bit
um headache was one of the first public
publicly traded Bitcoin miners we went
public in early 2018 originally on the
Toronto Venture exchange and then over
time moved up to the Toronto uh Stock
Exchange and then were the first
Canadian public to do a list onto the
NASDAQ in June of 21.
I was brought in by the board in
December of 2020 and after had gone
through a particular particularly
difficult time during the bear Market I
mean all minors had had a rough go in in
that bear market and those that survived
um were people like who had Bitcoin on
balance sheet and we were able to use
that Bitcoin to help kind of weather the
dog days of that bear Market uh others
survived because they were mining uh
other coins that had different economics
and that was able to carry them through
um and when the board looked to to bring
on a new CEO one of the things that they
were that they were focused on was
somebody that had a background in
Tradition more traditional compute or
technology that had done transformation
work in the past uh that loved Bitcoin
um and and could start to think about
how to diversify the company to kind of
avoid that going through those that type
of a bear market experience again so I
came in first thing we did was really
focused on the balance sheet we cleaned
up the balance sheet as I say we dual
listed onto the NASDAQ just to drive
better Capital markets access more
liquidity
and then we we started growing the the
mining side of our business but also
we're looking at ways to
um to bring in fiat-based revenue
streams that were uncorrelated that
could kind of help dampen some of the
volatility of Bitcoin mining economics
because there's so many so much of
Bitcoin mining economics are out of our
control we obviously don't don't control
the price of Bitcoin we don't control
the global Network cash rate and we also
had the additional complexity of an
energy crisis and Energy's our largest
input cost and so we so we looked we
looked at the industry and made the
decision uh to purchase our high
performance Computing business from
another Canadian public company so we we
bought it as an already established cash
flowing business we have two data
centers in Toronto two in Vancouver one
in northern BC and they come with a
diversified customer base a variety of
products uh Cloud collocation managed
Services which
um is obviously getting a lot of
headlines today as we see in insatiable
demand for
um for gpu-based compute driven by the
explosion of AI and all of the
excitement in in that community and tons
of new startups in that space and and
really for
for GPU clustered compute unlike Bitcoin
mining compute which is done by Asics
and they really have to be in a
traditional data center environment you
need
um and of course we're interacting with
customers on that side of the business
so you need a billing team and a sales
support team and a network operations
center and all of all of those things
that um that go into giving a great
customer experience which doesn't exist
in a Bitcoin mining world where
predominantly we actually don't have end
customers when we're prop mining we are
really just putting the compute power to
the Bitcoin blockchain and receiving
Bitcoin in return so it's a very very
different kind of go to market motion
and but we my background is almost
entirely from the traditional Tech side
I spent 22 years in tradtech before
coming over to Hut and a lot of it in
Data Center and infrastructure so I
really see a world where over time the
type of computing that we do in a
Bitcoin mine which is really really
um a lot of power
tons of density but we don't worry about
um excessive security controls or
redundancy it's all just single feed
power and it's really built to be a
flexible workload so the a Bitcoin mine
will power up and down on minutes notice
based on power pricing or the peak
demands of the local grid depending on
how how we're working with local
operators whereas a traditional data
center workload including GPU clusters
it's a net taker That Base you need a
stable base load you need to that data
center needs to be up and running uh 24
hours a day seven days a week and
there's a ton of complexity that goes
into how we ensure those data centers
don't go down at dual power feeds
multiple generator is UPS
um things that we don't need to have in
a Bitcoin mine where it's a flexible
workload and ultimately it's not
customer data that's being protected at
the end of the day it's just pure
horsepower being applied to the to the
algorithms
when you start looking at that high
performance Computing it's obvious how
the Bitcoin mining
um is very kind of straightforward and
as you described a bunch of advantages
to it are there things that you're
actually able to in the future
potentially put these together can
Bitcoin mines perform better or benefit
from actually going into some of these
you know kind of redundant type
facilities or is there an advantage to
keeping them separate facilities and
actually using what is kind of unique to
bitcoin uh and the mining process and
not trying to co-mingle these
so
impute does not play
pure the heat of the environmentals you
you don't you don't mix there were a lot
of experiments to actually bring
um acid compute into traditional data
center environments during the uh 1718
Bull Run and it was just proven out that
they it creates all kinds of
environmental imbalances within a
traditional data center environment and
frankly the cost is too high because if
you think about
um to build the infrastructure to
support a Bitcoin mine you're looking at
anywhere between kind of three hundred
and eight hundred thousand dollars per
megawatt depending how you build it out
whereas in a traditional data center
environment because of all the security
and redundancy you need you're looking
at you know it could be anywhere between
eight and thirteen million US dollars
per megawatt so really really massive
difference in approach and that is is
difficult to intermingle and again
primary differentiator is a traditional
data center is a is a net taker they're
always taking the power whereas the
benefit and beauty of a Bitcoin mine is
that it is a flexible load and can work
in conjunction with the Grid in a way a
traditional data center can't and I do
think we're going to see parts of these
worlds converge a little bit more over
time
um but it's still very much early days
we just talked about the differences but
the similarities are pretty obvious in
the sense of you're running servers or
computers and it's Hardware you got to
plug them in you got to take power and
then you got to do different things with
them uh that's right talk a little bit
as to uh kind of the story right for
public markets so much of public market
investing is about the narratives about
the story of a company and being able to
say look it is two different things and
there are differences in those things
but also there is this commonality that
positions you all at kind of the
Forefront or the tip of the Spear of
computing for this next generation of
all of these different applications how
do you think about what that story
really is and the power of being able to
share that versus just being you know
kind of a single focused Bitcoin miner
yeah I think really the power comes in
our ability to to flex as as market
demand and
um and economics evolve we also can
drive synergies from things like a
network operations center that is
monitoring is there to monitor our uh
data center sites 24 7. there are things
that they can do to help Emma on the
Bitcoin mining side as well which are
also running 24 7 but with with a
different type of Manpower outlay and of
course you always have synergies when
you're when you're looking at the
corporate structure so from
um all of the corporate functions that
that support our Bitcoin mining side of
the business can can equally support our
data center side of the business and and
again I do think we're going to see an
increased world of convergence and
there's all kinds of innovation
happening behind the scenes on
um you know can can potentially
gpus go into a container type of
environment and take advantage of some
of the lower cost are available at
Bitcoin mining sites how does how do we
how do we handle some of the network
connectivity issues for those types of
applications but that's certainly work
that's being done and I think we're in
the infancy of it but over the next you
know two to four three to five years
we'll continue to see products and
offerings and potentially
um even Hardware that starts to bridge
these worlds in a in a more meaningful
way than we've seen today
when you start thinking about Capital
allocation decisions obviously you have
a dollar to spend how do you think about
the return or the risk that you take by
diverting it to either side of the
business it's kind of this fascinating
exercise where maybe there's not just
one answer and there's some you know
variables there but how do you think
about that Capital allocation
yeah it's in in the Bitcoin mining side
of the world when we think about
allocating Capital how we look at it you
have to you have to run massive
sensitivity analysis where you're really
guessing on where the price of Bitcoin
and Global hash rate are going to be at
any given point in time in that in that
return profile that you're building for
the investment in in the mining Hardware
in particular and that's why
um so we're actually in the middle of a
merger that's pending um pending final
approvals with a private Bitcoin mining
company called usbtc and one of the
things that we love about the usbtc
model they're Diversified uh in a just
like HUD is but rather than being
Diversified into HPC
um usbtc is Diversified into they do
prop mining but then they also do
hosting for other Miners and they have a
managed infrastructure operations
business which is really just uh think
about it almost as Professional Services
they bring their uh their bodies and
their purpose built software in to
manage Minds for for other people and
all three of those businesses have a
much much different Capital profile the
most intensive uh business across both
Huddy and usbtc's operations is prop
mining prop mining uh highly highly
highly Capital intensive a ton of
variables that you're really just
um kind of running sensitivity analysis
and and making your best guess on where
where the returns will go over a period
of time and whereas hosting much less
Capital requirement because
um the the client brings the mining
equipment and then the case of Mio
really no no capital investment at all
and then as I said on the HUD side prop
mining uh we also have a repair center
and then the HPC side so it gives us a
lot of flexibility based on what we're
seeing in the macro environment either
on traditional HPC or on the Bitcoin
mining side and we can kind of flex
between the different the different
lines when we think about what's the
best allocation of capital obviously in
a go forward State assuming we're
successful in our murder so obviously
you've got this kind of capital
allocation decision but there's also M A
which is another form of kind of capital
allocation uh you all seem to be one of
the more aggressive uh companies in the
public markets that have Bitcoin mining
but also are pursuing m a strategy
whether it's with other public companies
or private companies talk a little bit
about you know kind of the advantages
you see there maybe the opportunity set
in terms of uh choosing not to do this
once but it seems like now this is
becoming somewhat of a strategy so what
are you seeing there
from a bit of a unique
transformation and with distress and the
the strategy we took in the bull market
was to really
um focus on Shoring up the balance sheet
we have a large stack of Bitcoins we've
got over 9000 Bitcoin on our balance
sheet that's unencumbered very very very
little leverage in the business and
and my thesis was the Bitcoin
um cycle has always repeated in a very
similar fashion and so my I I was taking
the view that the last bull market would
eventually end and and we would roll
into a bear Market which is obviously uh
what we saw in this case the bear market
for minors in particular
um especially challenging on the back of
the energy crisis as well as
um lower Bitcoin prices and a global
hash rate that just continues to grow so
kind of The Perfect Storm uh for Miners
and uh in our case because we had short
up the balance sheet we had already
successfully
um done our first m a transition
transaction being the HPC business that
was integrated and and I really when
looking at kind of what was happening in
the market and the opportunities
available and it it felt to me like your
dollars were going to go further in
um through investing in inorganic growth
and organic particularly with the
challenges we've seen in the supply
chain so just really really high prices
across the board long lead times and
whereas in in the inorganic space
opportunities to
to do pickups that give you kind of an
immediate benefit without exposing you
to to the challenges on the inorganic
side and then when you start thinking
about those M A opportunities obviously
being a canadian-based business you've
done some stuff in Canada now you're
doing some stuff in the United States
are there other geographic regions that
you're focused on or think could be
strategic for you
I mean it's really important to look at
um geopolitical risk not just not just
short term but long term and that can be
a challenge we also kind of markets that
I that I really liked
um ended up not faring well in the
energy crisis so that kind of changed
the perspective there I think
um some of the technology we're seeing
continue to advance in immersion the
economics are starting to get more
attractive that opens up hotter climate
markets and I think the UAE in
particular has done an incredible job of
really attracting some of the best and
brightest in
um in digital assets from across the
globe and and certainly have a very
um open easy to navigate regulatory
environment and but
it remains to be seen from a mining
perspective what what um might make the
most sense
but certainly open to it and I and I
like the jurisdiction yeah that makes
sense um when you think of Regulation
you talk about the jurisdiction there
but what about in the United States or
in Canada how has that affected decision
making for yours yeah I think we're
we've got the fortunate position of
really just being focused on bitcoin
it's only Bitcoin we hold on our balance
sheet we really are just infrastructure
as far as
um as far as the the markets are
concerned we don't interact uh directly
with with retail consumers or any any
other kind of token and I think really
the focus in the US uh right now from uh
a regulatory perspective is more is more
focused on exchanges and other types of
Securities or seems to be broad
consensus that Bitcoin uh is a commodity
and uh certainly
um that's that's what we feel as well
one of the challenges we're seeing on
both sides of the Border in in Canada in
certain jurisdictions in the U.S is
really
um some in some cases a lack of
understanding about how Bitcoin mining
really works and how it can benefit
local grids in local communities and so
in an absence of understanding we've
seen uh unfortunately some mining
moratoriums or mining bans so it's
really
it's really a jurisdiction by
jurisdiction in Canada Province by
province the U.S state by state and as
to as to how how mining's being
perceived and and that I think as an
industry one of the areas that that we
really need to be focused on is
education and really kind of breaking
down a lot of the misunderstanding that
that surrounds Bitcoin mining and and
drive more conversations that lead to
kind of thoughtful regulation and and us
being able to really partner with grids
and communities in a way that benefits
all parties which I think is the unique
beauty of this type of load and there is
no other industrial scale
um Power consumer like Bitcoin mining
that can that can work seamlessly with
and to help support the grid uh but also
to stabilize them and help monetize
without the need for government
subsidies or intervention my last
question is that you are not a Bitcoin
ludite you didn't necessarily you know
uh kind of come to bitcoin and be like
oh my God the government's gonna fail
and I'm going to get rich because of
this uh you've had a very impressive
career uh maybe what are some of the
surprises as you've gotten deeper and
deeper into the Bitcoin Market into kind
of the culture of Bitcoin into the
mining process is there anything that
kind of sticks out to you that was
either kind of an assumption that ended
up not being true or maybe something
that was a surprise as you kind of built
all this out
certainly the biggest surprise was how
supportive and collaborative the entire
Community is I mean coming from
traditional technology all mostly all of
my career was in large in large public
companies and I did a stint in in one of
the banks in capital markets and and
there's certainly there isn't the level
of collaboration kind of this Spirit of
community that permeates the our space
um that was the biggest surprise and it
continues to be we um all of the all of
the companies really in our space know
each other we're broadly trying to do
what's in the best interest of the
industry when when we think about
um you know we we created the Bitcoin
mining Council a couple of years ago
really to help bring
um a unified opportunity for us to speak
and and speak out in defense of some of
the the misunderstanding and the fun
that was permeating the headlines often
about the energy use and and so I think
really just doing as much work as we can
as an industry to educate again
critically important but biggest
surprise for me is just the the amount
of positivity and really at the end of
the day everybody wants the industry to
be successful and is are supporting the
participants in order to ultimately get
us to the place that we think this
industry uh deserves to go
Jamie where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about how to eat
uh I have the great benefit of a name
that doesn't exist on anyone else on the
planet so at Jamie leverton the way I
spell it if you Google it assuming you
don't find one of my imposters uh it's
literally at Jamie leverted on Twitter
on LinkedIn I'm super super easy to find
as is Hot 8
website.io and and really just super
thrilled to be here awesome thank you so
much for doing this we'll definitely do
it again in the future
that would be great thanks Mom
[Music]